I'm gonna take a few minutes today to
tell you about a really exciting
blockchain project that we are
partnering with called silica this is
the second video in a two-part series we
are doing you can learn even more about
silica by going to their website I've
put the link right down underneath the
video
what makes silica such an interesting
project is that it solves a very big and
very real problem that blockchain and
cryptocurrency are facing and it's a
problem that's inhibited the utility and
the adoption of blockchain and that is
the problem of scalability and of course
what I'm talking about here are the
limitations that some of the most
popular block chains have in their
ability to grow as a network and to keep
processing more and more transactions
two well-known examples
Bitcoin and aetherium they have inherent
constraints in their capacity to expand
to scale and this ability to scale is
crucial for many blockchain use cases
especially enterprise use cases so
there's a lot of competition in the
blockchain space to meet that need and
to develop a protocol that can further
scale in order to bridge the gap meet
the demand of businesses and projects
that require it
so Silica's approach to solving this
problem has been to develop a brand new
blockchain protocol where throughput in
other words the network's ability to
process transactions goes up as the
network gets bigger and the way that
they do this is through a mechanism
called a shard each node of the
blockchain network is divided into
shards which are sort of like sub
networks and it's the multiple levels of
this hierarchy which are processing
transactions in parallel that multiply
the total throughput of the network and
allow it to scale in a linear fashion
the more the network grows the more
transactions that it's actually able to
process and zelicah is the first
blockchain platform ever to implement
shards in this way to use shards as a
solution for scaling on a public
blockchain so that is like the crux of
Zillah cos unique offering and what has
allowed it to gain
so much traction in terms of adoption I
talked a little bit about Zil hive in my
previous video I want to fill you in a
little more about that which is really
interesting
Zil hive is a program that silica has
put together to engage with and give
back to the community and it encourages
the development and adoption of apps
built on silica through a pool of five
million dollars in grants that go to
projects teams and individuals that are
building tools and apps with silica and
doing research on the platform and the
grants target entrepreneurs who are
building the most innovative apps that
tokenized real-world assets and enable
the issuance of digital identity enabled
the exchange of goods and services in a
digital marketplace these are three
rapidly emerging use cases for Zillah
cos technologies and ones that they are
doing a lot to try to bolster couple of
cool updates on silica and what they've
been up to since my first video was
published a couple of weeks ago silica
announced the new partnership with a
platform called switch IO to build a
noncustodial decentralized exchange
index and the new silicon decks will
allow silica token holders and traders
to tap into digital assets on the
etherium blockchain for the first time
ever the new decks will have an atomic
swap protocol that will allow traders to
do automatic digital asset exchanges
without needing a centralized
intermediary and users will also be able
to contribute to liquidity pools
allowing for consistent market making
while they get a cut of each transaction
fee number two silica also just issued
their to their community to introduce
staking to the network and this is a
really big deal because it's something
the community has been waiting for since
day one on the main net and they're
going to be building out the staking
over the next few months they'll
incorporate feedback from developers
token holders and miners in the silica
community which is great it's clear
silica is constantly engaging and taking
direction from people who are invested
in the platform and the idea there is
build up the ecosystem in a way that
will benefit everybody involved I've
really enjoyed talking about silica in
these two videos you can check out the
first one I did
I want to thank silica for partnering
and collaborating with us on creating
this content
there are many blockchain projects out
there but this is one that's really
doing something new and useful with
scalability check out silica using the
link underneath this video subscribe to
their newsletter follow them on Twitter
they have a big big following they also
have some really interesting stuff going
on right now definitely a project you'll
want to continue paying attention to in
the future